we sort of are at the point where we
need to have a serious conversation
about the relationships that the united
states
has or had or we i guess
hope continues to have at least that's
my view with
other countries particularly many of our
long-term allies because i don't know of
any other way to say this
other than to say a whole bunch of world
leaders have had it with trump
and they're not making any effort to
hide it anymore and it's becoming
extraordinarily embarrassing for us on
the world stage
and if you are a so-called nationalist
as donald trump claims to be
and as many of his followers now are
also claiming to be
um if you are someone who is in the
uh who cares what others think
camp of the right if you don't
understand why it matters
that other countries are laughing at us
because of trump
then this story may not really change
your mind
but it should uh for the people in our
audience
who understand that in 2018 we have a
globalized
networked world we have problems that
cross the imaginary lines that we see on
a map but not when you look at
what the earth looks like from space
climate change
doesn't respect borders interlinked
economies
don't respect borders global inequality
is a problem that goes beyond
national borders if you understand why
it matters
that we have good relationships with our
allies then you are going to be very
concerned
once you realize that what was before a
sort of respectful distance from
trump that many world leaders were
keeping
that has now become an attitude of
direct and clear
indictment of trump as someone that they
just don't consider
serious as a diplomat they don't
consider serious as a world leader
because he isn't that's the reality
fareed zakaria from cnn interviewed the
french president emmanuel macron
over last weekend and macron said he
doesn't do
diplomacy via twitter again another
very direct attack on donald trump take
a look obviously
your expression about the european army
uh
irritated president trump he tweeted uh
something about it
do you think that there is an inevitable
clash here you are you know
we had a very good discussion this
morning and he confirmed um
in front of the press that he was he was
okay
i think does that mean that his tweet
was a mistake
i don't know i'm not the one to comment
his tweet uh i always prefer
having direct discussion or answering
questions at making my
my diplomacy for tweets
he prefers actually talking to people in
real life
rather than doing diplomacy through
tweets but only
an indictment of what donald trump has
been doing and there's nothing wrong
to be clear about actually communicating
policy decisions or ideas or
or whatever via twitter if you are a
president the problem is how trump does
it
and the policies that he's communicating
the ideas he's communicating
which are horrendous and only make our
problems worse rather than resolving
problems
and then continuing to say simply
trump is wrong and he's a joke
emmanuel macron speaking over the
weekend at these world war one related
events one of which donald trump chose
to skip
in a direct attack on nationalism which
is donald trump's new thing
um emmanuel macron saying the old
demons are rising again and ready to
complete their task of chaos
end of death patriotism is the exact
opposite of nationalism nationalism
is a betrayal of patriotism in saying
our interests first whatever happens to
the others
you will race the most precious thing a
nation can have
that which makes it live that which
causes it to be great
and that which is most important its
moral values
they don't care though they don't care
they are
disgusted with donald trump at this
point
their willingness to say it is
increasingly clear
and you'll notice the moment at one of
these events
were vladimir putin was arriving when
you look at
what is taking place here angela merkel
and emmanuel macron
not looking thrilled with vladimir putin
and donald trump
just unable to contain himself loving it
no one in this picture as excited and
thrilled about vladimir putin's presence
at donald trump trump
moments after this picture was taken
flashing a
thumbs up to putin which was sort of odd
given the circumstances of the event as
these armistice day and
commemoration of the deaths of so many
troops
very very strange behavior putin the
murderer
putin the poisoner putin the repressor
and the annexer of
crimea the attacker of american
democracy and donald trump is just so
taken with him that it should make us
all sick and it's not just vladimir
putin
it's president erdogan it's the
extraordinarily
funny and smart kim jong-un of north
korea
it's bashar al-assad in syria it's i
mean who am i missing here pat rodrigo
duterte
in the philippines the people try i'm
missing some right i must be missing
somebody here
no that seems to me like the entire list
of authoritarian dictators that trump
likes
i i think this is all going to do
irreparable damage to
america's image across the world because
even if we get
a progressive democrat in office in 2020
i don't think that uh
world leaders are going to look too
highly at the united states even if we
do things like
get back into the paris climate accord
or
reinstitute the iran deal i think that
global leaders are going to understand
that
all this stuff is flimsy and that
america could just elect another
republican president who's going to pull
out of all those things
it's it's unstable i think this is now
the problem
this is why you know at the beginning
you saw that respectful distance
from the leaders of countries like
germany
and france and the uk and others and at
the time
or to date there had been a lot of
executive orders there have been a lot
of
horrible plot proclamations made on
twitter but there hadn't been as much
irreversible action taken we now were
talking about
a total 180 on the issue of climate
uh we are talking about getting out of
the iran deal
unilaterally without iran having
violated the deal which makes
every country question whether the
united states can be relied upon
to make any kind of deal with because
whoever's there might just say you know
what i don't like this deal we're out of
this deal
the alliances that have been destroyed
including via economic decisions
like the tariffs that donald trump has
put in place
the list at this point as pat points out
of bells that cannot be unrung
to use an analogy or genies that have
been out of the bottle that you can't
get back in
toothpaste that is out of the tube
whatever analogy you want
this is going to take a very long time
to undo and this is why
many of these leaders are realizing hey
the idea
that we can just kind of play coy with
this and go
forward as if it's not insane what's
going on with donald trump in the united
states
it's over it's over and they are moving
forward on climate change without the
united states i told you earlier in the
week monday or tuesday
countries are moving ahead in distancing
themselves from the dollar as their
reserve currency the tariffs are
certainly going to push that process
along
this is irreparable harm that is now
being done
send me your thoughts i'm on twitter at
d pacman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show one of today's sponsors
is skillshare which is an incredible
online learning community offering over
ten thousand
high quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics
first five hundred who click the link
under this video will get
two entire months of totally free access
to every single class that skillshare
offers you'll have
free access to courses on music art
photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between
i think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you
just took a really great class on
graphic design which i know
nothing about but i'm trying to learn
our show is giving you
two entire months of totally free access
to every course
skillshare offers risk free if you click
the link under this video
you'll have two months to take classes
on anything you're passionate about
classes taught by
real people who share that passion and
after that you can keep getting access
to the entire site
for less than 10 bucks a month just
click the link under this video to
redeem your two free months of
skillshare
but hurry it's only available to the
first 500 who sign up